[Music]
i'm pretty sure it's going to be you
but it wasn't a young black man jailed
on a warrant for a white man twice his
age
it is a story that had many of you
talking after our 8 news now i-team
first reported it earlier this year now
we have the videos the i-team's david
charns with this exclusive report and
the city's new response
brian it is a case of mistaken identity
that's the subject of a federal lawsuit
a young man with the same name as a
felon caught in the middle of this
mix-up we filed a public records request
for these videos and as you will see we
received them with the officers faces
blurred
stopped you because you didn't have any
headlights on at all this is how shane
brown's nightmare began all right
let me see your driver's license it's 4
44 in the afternoon on january 8 2020
henderson police pull him over i do have
a one with you guys but i have a court
date tomorrow
brown telling the officer he'll be in
traffic court the next day my license is
also suspended for that reason i'm
taking care of all more yeah i'm taking
care of all that tomorrow he doesn't
have his license with him but he gives
his name what's your uh middle name
his birthday and social security number
just go ahead
officer is asking brown to get out of
the car since his license is suspended
as brown sits on the sidewalk the
officers say this about his court
appearance the next day
[Music]
[Applause]
but within minutes everything changes so
we got to figure some stuff out
you got arrested for something with a
weapon
at least that's what they're saying
they're not ringing the bell
it doesn't ring a bell because this
shane brown a black man in his twenties
has never met this shane brown a white
man in his late forties las vegas metro
police want this shane brown on a felony
gun charge when officers in henderson
tell this shane brown he's a wanted
felon he's understandably confused
i've been arrested but everything i've
been arrested
officers don't buy that answer arresting
him on that felony warrant coming back
totally matching you
not much else
i've never been arrested for
so do me a favor but just put your hands
right behind your back in my opinion i'm
not sure how that warrant comes back
tied to
this young man here we showed the videos
he's very confused to retired nevada
state police captain scott martin so as
someone who did internal affairs is this
something you might investigate
yes
isn't it on them rather than on him it's
been my experience and it's my opinion
that
an investigation out on the scene has to
take place to be able to be 100 percent
sure oh my social's in there too okay
the wrong shane brown this one pleads
with officers to double check knowing
he's not the one wanted on a weapons
charge the officer is speaking with each
other again
whether it is or not if they're not
called dispatchers pinging off of his
social so it's a nobel warren
charge
so what do we want to tell the jail uh
he has weapons he has a weapons check
could the records have been
wrong there could have been a mix up
with his social security number with the
other
warrant for the traffic citation the
i-team found the no bail warrant for
this shane brown features the unique id
number police agencies in southern
nevada all share a search with that id
number would have brought up at least
these two prior booking photos for this
shane brown the most recent one taken
months before the younger shane brown
was now in handcuffs how long is that
that warrant isn't me am i good to go
that fell anymore
yeah but i'm almost 100 i don't think
i don't know i'm pretty sure it's going
to be you court records the i-team
located attached to the id number and
the warrant show this shane brown is
white born in 1971 with brown hair and
blue eyes if we could do it couldn't
they have done it
absolutely i couldn't believe
that they didn't find
or that they did not figure out that
he's not
the right brown
the wrong shane brown ended up spending
two nights at the henderson jail two
days later brown boarded a bus spending
four days here at the clark county
detention center corrections officers
there rebooking him giving him an id
number different than the shane neil
brown police actually wanted your honor
we have a
major issue
on this case
it wasn't until january 14th six days
after that traffic stop when a public
defender tells the judge the wrong shane
brown is in custody the shane brown who
is the defendant in our case has a
separate id number and he is a 49 year
old white male the judge had this
reaction make sure that
the same ground is in custody gets
released
immediately
and he was metro which operates the
clark county jail previously telling the
i team it does not comment on pending
litigation that's what the city of
henderson first told us too after we
reported this story earlier this year
they followed up with us saying brown
was quote correctly arrested on those
traffic offenses tonight and after you
just heard one of those officers say
arresting brown if he's in court
tomorrow could be quote dumb they tell
us his arrest was lawful again on those
traffic offenses a spokesperson though
adding this we regret that he was
misidentified in our system and have put
measures in place and improved training
procedures to prevent this from
happening in the future we did not
receive a response to our specific
questions about those procedures or what
happened to the officers i'm david
charns live local now